[Music]
are not my priority my priority are
people in the middle class and that's
where we're giving the big tax reduction
to it it's about the middle class and
it's about jobs and it's about bringing
jobs back to the country bringing back
the companies back so that companies can
get a reduction right now we're paying
the highest tax rate in the world
we want to bring that to around fifteen
percent that would make us competitive
with China and other countries so my
priority is bringing companies back
bringing money back into the country
there's trillions of dollars outside of
our country that we could bring back but
the taxes don't allow it to happen all
right that was the president earlier
today talking about his tax plan while
he was visiting Florida joining us now
with reaction editor-in-chief lives that
Fox News contributor and nationally
syndicated radio host Laura Ingraham I
am a big supporter of the president's
economic plan I like the idea of
middle-class cuts I like the corporate
15% rate there were patreon I think he's
right corporations multinationals will
build factories manufacturing centers
that's going to help people that
desperately need jobs that are in
poverty out of food stamps he did say
about he did say about the wealthy
they'll be the same or it might be a
little higher Reagan went from 70 to 28%
is that a important component or does it
not matter in terms of the economic
growth that we want to see that'll
create millions of jobs look I think the
Tax Simplification tax reform get it
down to four rates get rid of a lot of
the deductions except for the three core
ones charitable home deduction child
care tax credit I think that's that's
good policy I think taxes are too high I
think their tax decks are too high for
everyone
but not everyone's going to get
everything they want in this tax deal
that's clear but unfortunately Congress
has kind of tied the president's hands a
little bit because of course they didn't
get the Obamacare repeal through Sean so
you know we're we don't have those
savings that we thought would have
before we went and embarked upon this
tax reform I think the president's right
on those key issues and I know
immigration you're talking about tonight
as well but wages are really an
important part of this and
companies like to keep wages low but
we've had wages flat had a little uptick
last month but we've had wages flat
since like 1999 in real dollar terms you
got to have it put a squeeze on
employment a scarcity of employment will
raise wages so we can't be cute we can't
keep doing amnesties that bring more
amnesties that bring more people into
the country that keep working class
wages low either so that's a critical
part that's why this amnesty thing is so
important I agree I love every part of
the plan I also think energy does so
many there's millions of high-paying
career jobs for a lot of people and
that's going to be fundamental for a lot
of people but Reagan when he cut the top
marginal rate from 70 to 28% the
predictions were
buddhu economics but 20 million new jobs
were created longest peacetime period of
peacetime economic growth in history and
revenues doubled to the federal
government look if he does everything
else I think that covers the economy
what do you think about the battle
that's been going back and forth Schumer
and Pelosi and the president saying if
we don't get the wall we don't get any
deal on anything what is your general
thought on what's been happening all day
I think the president was successful
because he didn't listen to the very
experts who are praising his move last
night with Pelosi and Schumer and I know
there's been a lot of comments from the
White House and the president tweeted
out that it's not really amnesty but I
think he's he's really cool instincts
and I think partly what happened is when
he hears Oh enhanced border security he
hasn't been a big part of the amnesty
fights that we've been part of Sean back
in 2007 2013 so he's not he's not
familiar with that lingo he thinks when
someone says enhanced border security
that really means something but flying a
few drones around along the border and
promising you know promising more
funding is a boondoggle that doesn't
really mean anything you need the raise
act Tom Cotton's raise act you need the
e-verify and you need the wall you need
all three things before you start giving
legalization and benefits to 800,000
people plus you know their parents are
going to stay they're not going anywhere
it's really about 2 million 2.2 million
people he did not win Wisconsin Ohio
Pennsylvania
yeah by saying we'll repair the fence
you know in Arizona and by the way we're
gonna work with Nancy and Pelosi on
taking care of the do you agree with me
that if he makes those concessions and
he doesn't get the funding for the wall
up front he's never getting it I don't
think it'll ever get it if you don't get
it now never getting it the wall the
raise act Eve Arif I has to be part of
any deal you're never gonna have any
more leverage than you have right now
and if he says look I'm willing to hear
you out in the dreamers we're not we're
not sending rounding up people with
deportation forces no one's arguing for
that but we're not going to make the
same mistake we've made in years past
we're not going to he's not gonna stand
up and argue for the same points that
Marco Rubio and Jeb Bush argued for with
the same language almost after they
couldn't win their home state primary
Sean they didn't win because they were
arguing for much of the same language
that the a lot of the Trump advisers I
think are saying oh it's okay everyone
will swallow the the pill of amnesty
because it's a cult of personality
supporting you people supported him for
substantive reasons all right Laura good
good comments observations insights
appreciate it when we come back home